a
[Música]
bueno
puede un niño de 10 años colocar una
inyección intramuscular a los 14 hacer
suturas de heridas a instrumentar en
cirugías disecar piernas cadavéricas a
los 16 años entrar en la facultad de
medicina recibirse a los 21 años y
simultáneamente ser o hacer una carrera
de jugador jugador profesional de fútbol
y a su vez disfrutar del camino yo les
digo que se puede estoy acá para darles
algunos secretos el único problema que a
los 52 años van a terminar así
vengo de una familia de padre médico
madre maestra somos cuatro hermanos
casualmente actualmente los cuatro
hermanos somos todos médicos
y si hay algo que recuerdo de mi
infancia es que
desde chicos con nuestros hermanos nos
encantaban los desafíos nos encantaba
teníamos a flor de piel la palabra
aquino la frase a que no
y aquí no se hubiese ese árbol ya que no
te pase el marco de esa puerta aquí no a
que no
y a veces habían desafíos simples pero a
veces eran desafíos complejos que
aprendimos ahí que cuando había desafíos
complejos
aprendimos a superarnos
pero también aprendimos a reírnos de
nosotros mismos porque más allá de que
sea bullying nosotros nos cargamos entre
nosotros entonces aprendimos desde chico
a reírnos de nosotros mismos y
fundamentalmente agarrar los desafíos
con alegría
con alegría reírnos de nosotros mismos
y fundamentalmente desde chico conocimos
la frase de einstein que decía que para
lograr algo se necesita un 5% de
inspiración y un 95% de transpiración
una vez en casa se cortó la luz dos
veces
mis padres no sabían por qué nosotros y
con mi hermanos
nos planteamos el desafío de a ver
cuánto aguantamos con los dedos en los
enchufes
lo hace primero mi hermano se corta la
luz y qué tal no nos bárbaro dice mi
hermano prender la luz va a fernandito
tak se corta la luz de nuevo y ahí
aprendimos que había desafíos que pueden
ser peligrosos inclusive pueden matarte
nuestra casa estaba al lado de la
clínica mi padre el médico de la clínica
mi madre la administradora por lógica
estábamos siempre adentro de la clínica
era lógico que iba a surgir el primer
desafío médico cuál fue el primer
desafío médico a quien no te animas a
colocar una inyección intramuscular a
que sí
y surgió la pregunta como una pregunta
que me hizo mi amigo cuando yo dije que
iba a venir a esta charla me dice dale
para adelante que puede morir sal que
puede manejar nada entonces le
preguntamos a nuestro padre que puede
morir sal no si se lo coloca en el
ciático queda paralizado si se infecta
puede tener una gangrena se puede morir
ah bueno entonces empezamos a
capacitarlos y a capacitarnos pero no
aparecía nunca la nalga estábamos
buscando la nalga
se enferma nuestra madre
necesitaba una infección intramuscular
ahora había que capacitarse el doble
porque el compromiso era colocar la
inyección no hacerle daño y era nuestra
madre nuestra madre
logramos superar ese desafío y ahí
aprendimos qué
que cuando uno aplica una práctica
médica sobre una persona tiene que
considerar como que si fuese la madre
y aprendimos lo que es el corazón
bondadoso y una nalga voluptuosa
de una madre comprometida con el
desarrollo de sus hijos
madre que nos ha dejado hace un mes
y quiero recordarla en estos momentos en
este momento la gran la gran noche
desde ahí ya superamos la primer parte
dijimos bueno colocar la infección a
nuestra madre seguimos aprendimos a
hacer canalizaciones aprendimos a
disecar aprendimos a instrumentar en
cirugía
y a los 14 años yo ya tenía las dos
pasiones definida el fútbol y la
medicina el fútbol después del mundial
78 yo quería ser el tolo gallego
sí
hasta trataba de caminar como el hito
entonces dije bueno a ver 14 años mira
si quiere ser como el tolo gallego te
tienes que ir a probar a rosario vamos
listo fuimos a rosario me pruebo en
olimpia y en renato cesarini me dice no
mira pibe como vos está lleno y tienes
que ir a buscar algo de menor calidad
está bien me fui a nube ya central
30 minutos en cada lado
30 minutos de práctica en cada lado y yo
había quedado en nivel y en central
como soy hincha de nivel y en ese
momento quiero decir en ese momento
porque no quiero herir susceptibilidades
nivel era mejor que central ese mundo
me decidí por new girl y ahí empezó un
poco la dinámica de mi vida tenía que
levantarme a las 5 de la mañana y longa
vapor que quedaba todo destruido de la
práctica del día anterior iba al colegio
a las 7 de la mañana antes trataba de
terminar todas las tareas salía rápido
al mediodía iba a comer a mi casa y me
iba a la ruta a cerdedo yo vivían
armstrong y de ahí empezaba a cerdedo
para para ir para rosario he ido con
camioneros he ido con reno fuego he ido
con citroen 13 horas tres horas de viaje
cuarenta minutos de viaje
y siempre iba con el libro siempre con
el libro repasando una lección
preparando la tarea del otro día
estudiando anatomía siempre con el libro
y ahora cuando estaba preparando la
charla digo muchas era igual que como
son los adolescentes ahora nada más que
los adolescentes ahora están con el
celular y que a veces los adolescentes
lo que miran es lo que está de moda
actualmente no lo que a veces quieren
mirar yo miraba los libros que quería
mirar
y a la vuelta eran como viajes de
adolescente cuando volvíamos de rosario
para armstrong
yo siempre con el libro siempre con el
libro salvo que en el colectivo
se haga alguna broma algún compañero
haya alguna chica de carne y hueso más o
menos como para justificar cerrar el
libro
y fue un año de bastante sacrificio
entonces ahí surgió la idea loca dije a
ver yo tengo 14 años tuve un segundo
voy a rendir tercer año de la secundaria
libre hacia el año siguiente voy a
cuarto año y después rindo el quinto año
libre y el ingreso a la facultad una
papo ya era fácil
entonces pregunté se puede no no no se
puede ir porque no se puede no no porque
no espero porque no no porque no y a mí
no me gusta aceptar un por qué no sin un
justificativo lógico entonces seguí
investigando y no había nada que lo
nieguen me puse a estudiar entonces los
viajes ya llevaba más libros ya siempre
de lleva tres ya llevaba cinco le
preguntaba a los camioneros para
resolver problemas matemáticos le
mostraba fotos de cadáveres a los
camioneros imagínense un señuelo
voy a rendir las primeras tres materias
como salí mal
voy a rendir la cuarta biología era lo
mío era lo mío ya que es 10 mi primer
material libre de tercer año de ahí
empecé a repetir todas bien y empecé en
cuarto año cuando empezarán y el cuarto
año empecé a cursar cuarto año llega a
fin de año y digo bueno voy a rendir el
ingreso a la facultad porque porque las
tres materias que rendía el ingreso a la
facultad eran las tres materias que yo
tenía que rendir el secundario
en esa época había examen de ingreso
hago el cursillo rindo con esas tres
materias de 2500 aquí el puesto 65
nada más que tenía que rendir ciento año
libre me faltaban una pavada
bueno voy a rendir esas mismas tres
materias que era el mismo contenido de
quinto año y adivinen cómo salir mal
yo digo lo de la facultad no sabía nada
la cuarta biología arreglo bien y había
entrado a la facultad pero me faltaban
las tres materias del ingreso a la
facultad rendirla en quinto año de hecho
fui y la rendir bien gracias a dios
y lo interesante que los profesores que
me habían luchado en esas tres materias
después fueron pacientes míos
qué que qué bueno que perdonar es bueno
y así es bueno me mudo a rosario y
gracias a dios la tuve a mi abuela está
mina que me acompañó después conocí a mi
señora a mi actual señora
con quien estoy casado hace 31 años y
tengo tres hermosos niños ya grandes
[Música]
era cada vez más difícil porque era cada
vez más exigencia nivel era tratar de
ser el mejor mucha competitividad
necesitaba organizar
y tiempo bastante bien y pasaron cosas
interesantes por ejemplo yo jugaba y
como ya estaba estudiando medicina el
que jugaba conmigo se le daría el
estómago y el abdomen y messi ha hecho y
fernando qué te parece y yo estudiaba y
veía y ya de me di cuenta que me gustaba
medicina del deporte hice dos veces el
curso de medicina el deporte antes de
recibirme
y llegó un día el mago aguilar el mago
aguilar era un masajista en esa época no
había kinesiólogo pero ese hombre era
masajista kinesiólogo profe
nutricionista era todo me dice bueno por
prescripción médica hay que colocar
inyecciones intramusculares los
miércoles y los viernes a todos los
jugadores 150 inyecciones papitas baldor
y empezamos entonces con el mago
empezamos a investigar porque entonces
vieron que cuando el arquero ataja a
mano cambiada le dice bueno hasta sacó
la pelota a mano cambiada a nosotros
también teníamos nuestra propia técnica
de inyección a mano cambiada pintábamos
los dos cachetes él volvía bakayoko
niega
y hacíamos con cachetazo sin cachetazo
con aguja cargada una variabilidad
impresionante
no escribimos ningún libro sobre eso
y un poco quería traer ese tema acá
porque el mago aguilar todavía no ha
recibido
el reconocimiento que tiene que haber
recibido el nobel ojalá que después de
esta charla surja aunque sea aún alguna
palabra para el mago aguilar de parte de
parte de nieve les dijimos con mis con
mi novia y si nos casamos bueno tales
como casa novel y no sería no tiene
sueldo si ella tiene un sueldo yo tenía
mi primer contrato en google y era época
de renovación veníamos de haber salido
su baño dos años subcampeones yo estaba
en el plantel de primera bueno voy
hablar con los dirigentes voy a hablar
con el dirigente de dominion estuvo
casada quiero ver si me van a renovar
usted tiene contrato por 25 años
fantástico nos casamos a la semana
estábamos pintando el departamento con
mi señora está telegrama de jugador
libre
equivocado me voy cuando llegó y
utilizaba de fernando que el fútbol las
cosas pasan rápido
jugador libre la cuestión es que
nosotros ya no nos alcanzado para comer
ahí en ese momento y dijimos que hacemos
momentos de incertidumbre de reubicar
los objetivos y tuvimos suerte nos
recomendó una persona para ir a jugar a
japon nos tomamos un año de luna de miel
con mi señora en japon jugué para
toshiba y me subí al circuito
internacional me pagaban para usar la
ropa cobraba dinero en dólares puntuales
ya empecé a anotar y a vivir el
resultado del sacrificio de la
adolescencia me dicen está la cosa de ir
a tenerife
vamos listo venimos a argentina estando
en rosário teníamos 15 días acá me
invitan unos amigos a jugar al fútbol y
pasó lo que no tenía que pasar me rompí
el ligamento cruzado el ligamento
interno menisco externo y no sé si había
otra cosa más rota pero tenía muchas
cosas rotas
vamos del otro lado ahí ya me puse del
otro lado ahí empecé a valorar
empecé a valorar a ese niño que le daba
la palabra de aliento cuando estaba en
la clínica de amstrong al que a veces
hacía electroestimulación a los
pacientes de armstrong
empecé a valorar las palabras de
optimismo la gente que tenía al lado y a
su vez a evaluar
las salas de espera los tiempos de
espera las consultas rápidas las
múltiples consultas porque ninguna
consulta me satisfacía tomar una
decisión equivocada operarme que no ande
bien no poder jugar más al fútbol con 21
años y medio un 22
él
había que reorientar un poquito los
objetivos y desde ahí
de presión de por medio me recibo y
empiezo a estudiar traumatología
y me puse como objetivo algo que el
nivel nos decían permanentemente nunca
te creas el mejor pero intenta hacerlo
pero con un pequeño cambio porque yo
trataba de ser el mejor y me recibí de
traumatólogo de deportólogo de
traumatólogo del deportivo cirujano
artroscópica hice un reloj internacional
pero no por mí no por mi pensando que el
próximo paciente que iba a tener ahí
podría ser mi madre o podría ser mi
abuela como fue yo le puse una prótesis
de cadera o podría ser mi hermano cómo
fue que le puse un le hizo una plastia
de ligamento cruzado
entonces ahí aprendí a tratar de buscar
ser el mejor no solamente en la parte
médica sino en la parte de ser humano
y bueno a mí me dijeron que dar esta
charla iba a movilizar muchas cosas en
mí y de hecho lo hizo porque me permitió
ver
él porque él para que él con quien él a
quién
a dónde voy
dije tienes casi la
y viene acá para para decirles que
busquen desafíos los desafíos son
excusas para vivir la vida intensamente
ahora tengan cuidado con los desafíos
algunos desafíos los pueden matar
busquen desafíos que sean buenos para
ustedes y para la gente que está
alrededor
que sean productivo para la sociedad y
después sean apasionados sean
organizados sean perseverantes los
éxitos se logran con la sumatoria de los
fracasos los genios no existen los
genios no existen a mi entender existen
personas que tienen desafíos bien
definidos que son organizadas
apasionadas perseverantes que tienen la
suerte de tener el ambiente que permite
que eso que ellos se desarrollen o la
inteligencia la inteligencia para poder
crear ese ambiente para desarrollarse
pero fundamentalmente fundamentalmente
disfruten del camino agradezcan le a la
gente que tienen al lado agradezcan le a
la gente que les permitió ser quienes
son
y en cualquier rubro de la vida en
cualquier rubro de la vida tengan en
cuenta
que les puede tocar estar del otro lado
y actúen con los demás como a ustedes le
gustarían que actúen con ustedes
y no puedo irme de esta charla sin
decirle una frase que me decían siempre
mis amigos futbolistas y mis amigos
estudiantes de medicina
ellos decían fernando bacci
como jugador y médico
[Música]
y como médico que jugador y no lo ponen
muchas gracias
[Música]